don't be afraid to be called a [ __ ] if
I really think about all those times I
didn't fight from for what would have
been closer to equal pay not even equal
pay because I was afraid to be called a
[ __ ] it's what they call you when
they're threatened by you or scared of
you I've been speaking about the gender
bias in Hollywood since I have been in
Hollywood since I've been earning a
living and needing to earn a living in
this industry
Hollywood has always seen as this beacon
of progression and liberalism and change
in reality it's quite different
[Music]
we don't typically know what those of us
those around us are making and you know
unset other actors other castes and
stuff but when these things are exposed
it is it's criminal how unfair the pay
gap is between men and women
[Music]
the number of women with speaking roles
speaking parts named characters remains
stagnant and the amount of women seeing
movies and making purchasing decisions
is only rising yet we are
representations are stories
representations of the female experience
is still chronically underrepresented
equality matters because you you never
stop fighting for what's right you don't
pick one thing that's right and fight
for that or focus on what's wrong here
and not these you the data that you
throw your hands up and you're just
content to accept injustice you're dead
we all are because if it's unfair for
one person it's unfair for us all
[Music]